growing up in the spotlight
he became team gb's great diving
potential
four olympics two bronze medals the real
prize always
just out of reach until now
as tom daley's husband reacted on
instagram at his home pool
i'm so proud of them the win they've all
been waiting for
is it quite emotional watching this it
really is yeah when you when
when you know the people and you've seen
them and you've watched how hard they
work and how hard they train six days a
week
twice a day they're just you know in the
water on dry land and for them to have
pulled it all together and got to this
point is just incredible
and for the next generation the
impenetrable chinese hold on gold has
been broken
by one of their own it gives you a lot
of motivation that
when you see it in front of you it
doesn't seem that far away
no you can i could do this they train at
this pool and sometimes we train
together
and it's it's really inspiring just to
see them how hard they train
and see all their work pay off and tom
daley has made his name
outside the pool too after coming out in
2013 he became a prominent voice
in the lgbt plus community i met someone
and they make me feel so happy
so safe well that's someone
who's a guy he married oscar-winning
writer dustin lance black and became a
father
three years ago so to speak oh that's
not to get
there is of course another half to this
diving pair too
23 year old matty lee who was at his
first
ever olympics but he probably never
thought in a million years that he would
be diving with tom daley
so to actually dive with tom and get a
gold medal at olympics
is probably beyond his dream really
still can't believe
this their stories are very different
but today
a new champion and an old olympian made
british history
and the teenager we watched growing up
coming so close
so many times finally became an olympic
champion
ali fortescue sky news